[Music]
the season 17 winter finale of grey's
anatomy left us with a massive
cliffhanger
did meredith gray die e.t spoke with
gray's executive producers andy reeser
and meg marines
about the shocking episode but first
let's break down what happened sometimes
when you think the storm has passed
you realize you were just in the eye of
it still feeling the effects of covid19
meredith appeared to be on the mend
after waking up from being in and out of
consciousness
but after seeing a coveted patient
coding across the hall
meredith went into hero mode dr gray
all right i'm in bagger
what the hell are you doing seconds
later though it became clear that
meredith
wasn't on the mend after all give me a
wheelchair
dr webber meredith's medical proxy made
the difficult decision to go against her
wishes
and put her on a ventilator to increase
her chances of survival
so the big question on everyone's minds
is meredith gray going to make it
reser tells e.t quote the virus keeps
everyone guessing and it's relentless
so it's going to take relentlessness to
fight it
and mourinh adds she's meredith gray
she's going to use every last bit of
strength she can to help
everyone we don't know what's going to
happen but if meredith has caught the
thing
we're hoping that she's going to fight
it showrunner krista vernov has
previously revealed that we will see
mick dreamy aka patrick dempsey make
more appearances this season
the dearly departed dock made a surprise
return weeks ago
in the dreamlike world meredith spin in
as she battles the virus reeser wouldn't
spill much but
did say it's definitely on the table and
it's definitely planned
and when it comes to rumors that this
could be the end for the long-running
medical
drama series mourinh says everything is
up in the air because of the current
real-life climate surrounding the
pandemic
reeser adds quote there's a difference
between in ending and
the ending elements of this season
definitely
involve in ending it's a sentiment
echoed by star chandra wilson aka bailey
who spoke with e.t earlier this month
there have been many
like oh this is how the season would end
this is how the series would end
conversations and then they all end up
you know
new because um
of a myriad of reasons because the
network's not ready the studio's not
ready the fan base isn't ready the
numbers are too good
uh you know all of those things and i
think that collectively
they create they've decided you know
what we're not going to put an end on it
we're just going to wait and see
um you know it's especially in light of
what's happening right now it's like do
we want the last season to be about
colvin
or do we want it you know us to be able
to put some nice ribbons
around it with rainbows and balloons and
things
so um i i know on the creative end
the conversation comes up but on our end
on the actor end
we're like look whatever it is that you
want us to do
whatever whatever life you see for these
characters
um you know as doctors we're we're ready
to bring that to life
so greater powers
to have those conversations